What's up, guys? Key fobs and more here,
and today we're going to be taking a
look at how to replace the battery in
your Chrysler Voyager remote. For this,
you're going to need a CR 2032 battery
and a small flathead screwdriver, both
of which will be linked in the
description below. To begin, you're
going to want to look at the bottom of
your remote and find the button to take
out your key. Next, you're going to take
your screwdriver, stick it in the slot
where your key was, and press
up. Going to use your screwdriver once
again. Stick it in that slot
there to pry out your battery. And put
your new one in. Positive side
up. Put your back back
on. Put your key back in. And that'll be
it. If you like the video, make sure to
share and subscribe.